never have I ever sabotage another actor
competing for the same role hi I'm Tommy
I've been a drama teacher for 15 years
hi I'm Mary and I've been a drama
teacher at 13 years hey I'm Eric and
I've been teaching drama like 10 years
hi I'm Jonah and I've been a drama
teacher for four years and this is never
have I ever I probably have - never have
I ever regretted my casting decision on
a show yeah yeah probably I have I have
had people that have underachieved and
overachieved I don't think I've
regretted a single lead casting decision
but you know over time there than the
occasional kind of medium-size roles
where there's a kid who doesn't quite
have as much interest I have not
regretted any casting decisions I feel
like I'm not gonna get specific because
I don't want to hurt people's feelings
that's a hard yes that's what it was
basically how it works is there's such a
fast audition process and sometimes kids
need more time to open up so sometimes
it's it's never like oh I casted this
person in the wrong part it's like I
wish I gave you more never have I ever
sabotage another actor competing for the
same role
no no never
I feel like that like compromises my
integrity as a person like I really just
want to be kind to everyone and really
I'm not like going out of my way to
sabotage is a bendable word I have been
in an audition maybe and like someone
didn't who was missing a side or maybe
they didn't get the character right and
I could have been like it's like this
but actually was doing competition
saying I'm right let's just keep it at I
have okay never have I ever forgotten a
line while on stage I have this is
recent in the musical I was in last
semester I literally was like going I
was laughing at something that was
happening in the audience and I went to
like sing my line and I was like and
then and then I like picked it up in the
middle um no one noticed it because it
was very brief I'm horrible at
memorizing lines I'm so bad at getting
it no no it's always been my biggest
fear and I and I fear it and I fear it
and I fear it but it never ends up
happening I've never forgotten a line on
stage because I work well under pressure
never have I ever had anything go wrong
during a show oh it wouldn't be theater
without something going wrong right in
terms of directing every every show with
the kids something goes wrong I also had
someone once have a nosebleed on stage
really yeah and it didn't fit oh it
didn't fit never have I ever already
knew who I wanted to cast before
auditions we have an idea no I have to
think about that you've never had been
like Oh Tiffany's definitely gonna get
the lead the thought is there but of
course like everyone has to auditioning
will give everyone a fierce it's a
responsibility factor too you know what
I mean like if this is the only
responsible kiddo who can like learn
this many lines you're the only one you
like in cast as this I think to me it's
a not really because I really enjoyed
in process so I I come in with such a
clear mind never have I ever recited
Macbeth on stage and had something bad
happen
still not never have I ever recited the
Scottish play on stage and had something
bad happen
I just want to notice that it doesn't
say Scottish play on this I added that
because you can't trick me into saying
say because I don't say it so are you
talking about Macbeth never have I ever
been jealous of another actors Talent
what I'm sorry I guess you've seen me
perform I'm Barry flip-flop because of
course like people get insecure it's
such a like judgmental like practice
you're literally judging people and like
your performance and like how you are is
what's at stake here kind of like what
you're providing is what's at stake but
like at the same time I'm great I don't
think any actor is perfect in every
single way right except maybe Meryl
Streep and you know seven moments where
I say okay well I feel great about this
this this and that's enough for me to be
a great actor but wouldn't it be cool if
I also had you know a little bit of you
know cumin on my spice rack and they've
got cumin in spades right and like Oh
wouldn't that be cool okay they don't
have something else you might have right
they don't have my nutmeg
there you go so there's that it's true
never have I ever thought about giving
up theatre no never
if anything I gave up other things to do
theatre this is really sad
yep we're so different
um I have I gave up theatre for three
years and run and did a business degree
because I got scared with how on such
and it is because it can be but then I
went back to it
sure what are you defining giving up
theater as I stopped doing it stopped
prison right yeah I stopped pursuing I
stopped doing I start doing classes I
stopped teaching everything even if you
go do something else you still pop he's
always gonna be live reading when I do
theater again right there points in my
life when I was definitely like I'm folk
seeing other things or their creative
aspects of my life I really want to
focus on but I've always come back to
theater that's the thing like you've
definitely considered and be like oh I
don't need this right now maybe I'll
never come back to it but I always have
come back to it so it's much like push
back like refocusing goes on in my life
and I feel like theater performance it's
home that was a fun game to meet it's
fun to just sort of think about your
history as a performer and a drama
teacher it's so funny to learn how
different we are yeah
theatre is really fun and theatre is
really complicated in a good way
and you know maybe give us a little bit
more street cred
[Music]